what's your advice to me I'm getting
married next year don't spend a bunch of
money on your wedding I think we're
going to be all in under 15 grand yeah
that's fantastic all brilliant probably
going to turn to 20 but yeah maybe 25
you bringing him yeah he's officiating
oh yeah what does that mean I get to
like you read the whole thing yeah and
then we say I do to minister just apply
online 20 bucks take me online Minister
it's easy easy where you going to do the
wedding we're between two places one is
a winery that we picked out and another
is a friend's house okay and so the
house would be a lot easier it's a
really nice place we could have it
basically the whole weekends but the
winery looks a little nicer for photos